in real life few of us would ever root
for someone to die but it's completely
different story when we're watching TV
knowing it's all just pretend allows us
to feel pretty good when we watch the
bad guys get what's coming to them
here are some moments we cheered at the
screen while seeing despicable
characters bite the dust
as you'd expect their massive spoilers
ahead Steve Newlin True Blood Steve
Newlin may have been a vampire but he
acted like a weasel initially part of an
anti-vampire crusade Nuland changes his
tune after becoming a vampire himself he
pulls a number of dirty tricks over the
show's first six seasons but Newlin
finally gets his just deserts in the
season 6 episode life matters roasting
to death in the Sun while screaming his
professions of love for fellow vampire
Jason Stackhouse all in front of his
adamantly anti-vampire ex-wife fangs for
nothing Steve George Foyet Criminal
Minds Criminal Minds plumbed into some
pretty dark depths with the story of
George Foyet aka the Boston Reaper this
psycho cut a bloody swath of destruction
for years tormenting the cops on his
trail until the case came to a tragic
conclusion in the show's fifth season
during Criminal Minds 100th episode FBI
agent Aaron Hotchner finally catches
Williams but only after he murders
Hotch's wife in a blind rage Hotch beats
Foyet to death with his bare hands
leaving millions of stunned viewers
wishing they'd tuned in to a re-run of
Dharma and Greg
instead Viserys Targaryen Game of
Thrones if you've ever read George RR
Martin's best-selling series you know
there's a lot going on and it would take
far too much space to detail the Royal
intrigue leading up to Viserys Targaryen
death and Game of Thrones suffice to say
that aside from being the exiled son of
an assassinated king Viserys is also a
pretty magnificent jerk even though it
was still only the first season of the
show when he drunkenly challenged his
only real Ally the horse Lord Khal Drogo
he'd already earned more than enough bad
guy points to deserve death by molten
metal crown fit for king sized tool of
course Viserys isn't the only person in
Game of Thrones with a death wish
Joffrey Baratheon Game of Thrones in a
way it's hard to blame Joffrey Baratheon
for being such a sniveling little creep
after all he was the product of
inbreeding and growing up in a royal
court man he was constant
spoiled still that doesn't excuse his
bloodthirsty rule as king or his
violence against women committed to
getting his own way at all costs
Joffrey proved a consistent irritant
during Game of Thrones first four
seasons so it came as a delightful
relief when he was poisoned by his own
grandmother in law at his wedding of all
the many many deaths Game of Thrones has
given viewers Joffrey's extermination
has to be the most satisfying Robert
Romano er unlike most of the characters
on this list er's Robert Romano wasn't a
killer or even a criminal he was just a
token smug doctor that every hospital
show has to have it's the actor palma
cranes credit that Romano ends up being
such as satisfying love to hate him
thorne in the staff side after being
introduced in the show's fourth season
he manages to offend alienate and insult
just about every other character all
while adding to the top-rated shows
consistently riveting drama Romano goes
out the bang in season 10 paying for his
TV sins by being crushed under a
helicopter that falls off the hospital
roof at that point we were more worried
about the helicopter Phillip Blake the
walking dead like any good sociopath The
Walking Dead's governor Phillip Blake is
a smooth enough talker to keep his true
nature hidden from his friends and
allies for a short time at least during
the show's third and fourth seasons
Blake's bloodlust and thirst for power
revealed in small increments by the time
we figure out he's a murderous lunatic
who keeps his zombified daughter
restrained in his apartment we're pretty
much counting down the days until his
death even for the Walking Dead the
governor's demise is pretty gruesome but
a viewer has ever wanted to see someone
get stabbed in the back shot in the head
and left in a field to be dismembered it
was all one eye speaking of putting your
eye out Gustavo Fring Breaking Bad if
you start selling meth for a living
you're bound to run into some pretty
unsavory characters case in point
Gus fring the powerful lethal dealer who
starts tightening a noose around Walter
White's neck almost immediately after he
reaches out to him about distributing
his perfect product throughout the
show's third and fourth seasons Gus and
Walter fight each other for the upper
hand in the relationship with enough
twists turns and double crosses for an
entire series we felt a powerful rush a
satisfaction when Walter finally got rid
of Gus by booby trapping an enemy's
wheelchair with a bomb that took off
half of Gus's face and a small chunk of
a nursing home
real nice well Arthur Mitchell Dexter
John Lithgow went from playing third
rocked and the Sons doofy sitcom dad to
giving us the creeps as Arthur Mitchell
the spine-tingling serial murderer known
as the Trinity Killer in the fourth
season of Dexter Lithgow soft-spoken
Demeter made him the perfect choice to
play a guy who's near perfect suburban
existence masks a terrifying urge to
kill this help fill an entire season
with a steadily mounting sense of dread
that still lingered even after Dexter
manages to finally put an end Michels
murderous ways in a sickening twist the
show undercut the viewers relief over
the Trinity killers death by revealing
that Dexter caught Mitchell too late to
prevent him from committing his last
murder
Dexter's own wife Rita Ralph Cifaretto
The Sopranos a career criminal whose
tendency toward violent outbursts was
overlooked because of his ability to get
things done Ralphie was a longtime Burr
and Tony saddle if Sopranos fans hated
Ralph after he murdered a stripper in
the parking lot of the gangs favorite
club they really couldn't stand him
after he started a stable fire that
killed a horse he owned with Tony he was
the last straw for Tony who offed Ralphy
with his own bare hands and disposed of
the body in pieces as Viserys Targaryen
taught us you don't want to mess with
the dude and his horses thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which TV death you
thought was the most satisfying